when people share good news about their
life people don't necessarily respond
positively you know they don't get
encouragement and people need so little
encouragement it's just unbelievable
your one voice often makes a difference
find yourself walking around just
complaining all the time around people
that complain a lot
man move or just try and do something
different change your life rise and
shine it's an expresso time what's up
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded onto the world so
let's start your day off right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message encourage others over to you
Jordan B Peterson I'm really sad to see
that people are disenchanted and
nihilistic and depressed and anxious and
aimless and perverse and vengeful and
and all of those things it's terrible
and then to see people question whether
that's necessary and then to start to
rise out of it it's like it's so fun
like last night I was at after my talk
it's overwhelming
I don't usually think about these things
but I was I was after my talk last night
and so all these people line up and you
know they have their 15 15 seconds with
me and they're kind of tentative they're
excited and a tentative when they come
up to talk to me and then they have you
know 15 seconds of time to tell me
something I'm really listening to them
and they're hesitant about whether or
not to share the good news about their
life you know and I think it's often
because when people share good news
about their life people don't
necessarily respond positively you know
they don't get encouragement and people
need so little encouragement it's just
unbelievable and so there comes
something good and then they call that's
so good you know somebody says I'm
getting along way better with my father
I haven't seen him for 10 years and now
we get along
not great and then the power of that you
can't overstate the power of that for
individuals to get their life together
the individuals an unbelievably powerful
force and every single person who gets
their act together a little bit has the
capacity to spread that around them it's
it's a chain reaction and so it's a
lovely thing to see so this is a really
heavy clip and it's a message I really
agree with I think most people's
environments suck I think most people
have friends parents relatives who don't
altima lisa port them and what they're
trying to do I think if you got some big
news and you got a million dollar client
your business is blowing up and you go
and tell your friends about your success
how many of them would truly be happy
for you how many of them would really
want to celebrate with you as opposed to
them saying good things but then
secretly just being jealous of your
success how many of us have friends like
that who just encourage us to no end for
people who are younger and have their
parents and you're still living at home
you still trying to figure your career
path how many of you are worried about
your parents judgment over what you want
to do you want to go off and do this
amazing thing but your parents want you
to do something else and you're afraid
to have that conversation it's why it's
so hard to break free it's why so hard
to break out because we are afraid to
share our dreams and our good news with
the people around us and we're afraid of
our dreams we have these bold visions of
what we want to do but doing the day to
day can be scary and you have one moment
of excitement but then the rest of the
week you fall back down is that Who am I
to do this and you don't have the
support system around you to help build
you up and it's why so many
entrepreneurs never actually take off
it's why so many entrepreneurs just our
Juan Trippe Renault's they are stuck in
their job and they don't want to they
don't want to leave the security blanket
they you know are stuck in their life
and they don't want to go against what
their parents want them to do or their
spouse or their kids and it means you
never actually get to do the thing you
want to do it means you never actually
get to live the life that you want to
live because you're constantly living in
fear of other people's judgments how sad
is it that you cannot share
good news with the people around you
because they worried about them judging
you and being jealous it's a big reason
why I started doing this I believe in
people quite often more than they
believe in themselves and because I have
that ability I think I have the
responsibility and I try to spread that
through everybody I touch in every
conversation I have and every video that
I make and I've received so many
comments from you guys saying that these
videos watch these videos on a daily
basis is your support network is the
encouragement because you don't have
people around you who can help and so
for yourself finding the thing because
living somebody else's version of your
life is never gonna be how you're gonna
win you're only going to be a junior
version of your parents or a junior
version of somebody else you will never
win you will never be happy you will
never be part of the 0.1% of the world
it's never gonna happen and so finding
the thing for you that gives you the
boldness and encouragement and
confidence to keep going every single
day whether that's watching the video or
having conversations or reading the book
or listen to a podcast whatever that
thing is may and it's so important and
then once you've found that for yourself
giving it to others it's so crazy how
much one supporter can make a difference
it's so crazy how if somebody's trying
to launch something and everybody is
against them and everybody's just saying
all the reasons why it's not gonna work
out and a lot of times it's out of love
and practicality but they're telling you
all the reasons why it's not going to
work out and one person comes along and
says I think it can do it I'm really
excited for you that one person
sometimes is all that person needs to
have a little bit of self belief and a
little bit of self confidence to believe
in themselves and chase that project so
I strongly encourage you to be that
person for the people whether that's
friends in your life if you see somebody
making a bold step or coming up with a
dream encourage them support them try to
help them instead of just showing why
something's not gonna work out if you
see a YouTube channel that you love and
support and you love watching their
videos and is new and isn't getting any
comments be the first person leave a
comment
I still love all the comments that come
in on this channel and please don't stop
leaving comments here but I remember
when I got started every single comment
most of the videos I put up got no
comments every single comment I got like
yeah somebody like this this is great
just a little bit of reinforcement and
so every time I'm watching a video from
a smaller creator if I don't see a
comment on it I'll be the first guy to
leave a comment because I know what
makes such a big difference not that
long ago a buddy of mine mark made a
video about how I forced him to get back
into making YouTube videos and I sent
all you guys over there and we left over
a thousand comments on his channel and
it made a huge impact on him and he was
speechless and now he's getting back
into making content for his channel I'm
I'm speechless guys I don't know what to
say
you guys overwhelmed me with with
support recognize though that you don't
need to be a thousand comments deep you
don't need to send a thousand people
somewhere to make an impact
you're one voice often makes a
difference when somebody's being hit
with ninety nine opposing opinions and
you're the one person who says I believe
in you I think you can do it
and you cheer them on just that one
piece of cheerleading is a lot of times
all people need and so want to encourage
you to find the thing for yourself
whether that's videos or books or
podcasts or whatever the thing is that
you need for me it's videos my videos
these videos I make self entry for
myself
the final thing that you need to set
your mind right to be confident to have
that self belief every day because once
a week isn't enough and then once you
find it for yourself just be a spark be
a light be a source of inspiration
encouragement for other people to go
chase their dreams as well now I've got
a really special bonus clip I think
you're gonna enjoy but before getting to
that my question that day is
I'd love to know who is one person on
YouTube that you love that we should go
show some support to leave their name in
the comments below
let's all go we check them out and leave
a comment on their latest video spread
some love show some support somebody
with a thousand subscribers or less
leave it down below and I think we could
all do a little bit of extra love to
spread our spark with the world so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus clip
[Music]
so of all the things in the world that
you could say are like the secrets that
being positive is one of the main things
that people need to do how did you
happen on that in life whether it's
personal or people around me when you
see people that are positive that look
at something good and something bad that
took place they move along in life
faster they're better and people want to
be around these people I mean too often
people gossip the one gossip person
wants to be around the other person that
gossips but they don't realize when you
gossip you're saying something you heard
about somebody else you're telling
everybody what if part of it was wrong
you had to go out and tell every person
you told this oh I'm sorry it was wrong
tell everybody you told it's not gonna
happen so it's things you learn about
don't gossip don't belittle people if
you don't have to god please don't try
and look at the positive angle what good
could come out of something and that
positiveness is gonna make you live
longer happier and wake up in the
morning happy not oh my god I gotta go
to work I can't wait till I get home I
want to retire because people are not
positive they were not happy and what
happens they retire they hate their job
they retire three or four years later
their debts they have nothing to do that
positive attitude be around positive
people encourage positiveness if you
find yourself walking around just
complaining all the time around people
that complain a lot
man move or just try and do something
different change your life being
positive and a positive attitude is find
something positive and something bad
makes you look for solutions when I was
down and out okay hmm
Oh pop bottles let's get the pop bottles
cash em in I love that because I until
you said that I knew that people
listening we're thinking what's easy for
you to be positive you're a billionaire
so but the fact that you were positive
even when you had to be looking for the
bottles recycle to make me to get you
99-cent meals that's incredible
as a generation if you create a huge
amount of positives negative will become
small if you create huge amount of
negatives they will become big and
positive will become small this whole
life is there has never been a point any
time and then
we'll be where everything is perfect
okay there's no such thing because life
is a possibility because it's a
possibility it cannot be perfect doesn't
matter what we do there's still
something more to do always that is why
it's an endless possibility striving
does not mean I want to be a good man I
want to be a good man
see being morally good he's only good
for the society not good for the human
being yes if if you're morally correct
it's good for people around you because
you contained but it's not good for this
life
so this life needs a little different
kind of nurture in that context how many
people in this world are going to stop
before you and may fall dead how many
people in how many people will be set
the seed that they will be striving to
be a better life than the way they are
right now a little higher expression of
life this is all your focus should be
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core values is that that people with
passion and not one drop of myself work
depends on your it's suppose to mean I
don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details